what I'm now going for it is this i'm
going to substitute through for the
actual subject rather than writing out
long time I have my 500 at the front and
then i use my a r and n in all the right
spots okay so what is the formula for
this summer 50 being a witch is 1.00 32
that and then ok times holidays are
right you can't get away from the
ickiness of radiant like that so there's
going to be wrapped at one point Oh
11.00 3 to the N because that's how many
turns in our commanders take away one
and then i'm going to divide by that
take my one so we're ready we're finally
at a point where we just go ahead and
now straight answer the question because
all of that legwork now lets us do in a
really simple way ok tell me what's
happening after five years that's that's
60 months yeah so all i need to do is
substitute in my n equal 60 that's worth
mentioning because like i said there's
no intervening party if I so wished I
could have gone straight to a 60 I would
have had to have generate this series
part and everything would be the same
except instead of an there be 60 and
then you go 6150 958 and at this point
I'd say 60 terms right but having done
this which is often necessary i'm just
going to substitute your success rate
now let's see if I
now I'm best took about them is just my
way of um just my way of practicality
okay I'm torture this before but this is
another perfect opportunity to remind
you your calculator has memory right
take advantage of memory when you have
gross looking things like this to put in
just to make it easier so when you have
a look right or is this I'm going to say
that's pretty damn it a little spice oh
this is a nobody huh hilarious thank you
make it out how you going you see that
ok so what's the UM what the key number
in my in my valuation is 1.0 one on one
point zero zero three and i'm going to
use it twice that's enough of benefit
for me so i'm going to write in one
point 01 / 1.00 three and i'm going to
go take that number well how about that
if you recall I'm gonna go shift store
there and then you give it a name so I'm
gonna call it hey so now I have that
number right I'm now going to reach for
my actual formula I'm going to go 5
minus x 1.0 03 wanna raise it to the
power 10 times such messages and then in
here instead of doing that awkward
fraction I just tried a maxima is alpha
to get to that age the power what again
16l 600 and take away one and then i'm
going to divide by one side is no man
take one right and then the right yeah
yeah yeah again as they operate like you
can also make that okay so
now they asked us for a particular level
of accuracy i believe which i just took
off the screen never helpful it's to the
nearest dollar to the nearest dollar so
they have given us this which is an
incredibly asian number okay wow did you
have four fours in if you couldn't get
any worse okay so there you go what
we're all the steps to if I did to the
nearest ten cents in a big 4440 four and
forty cents yeah and then I would just
fall over an eye out to be sure it's
pretty terrible okay even can be making
me out let's just rewind a little bit
what are the things our students had
difficulty with can you guess what's
inside difficult i didn't all the way I
screw though thinking that when I
generalize yeah please do things in the
bracket get out of binary news
thinking that kind of that by doing that
you get home yes you know what I don't
attack so this this is why it's so
important to establish that Pamela
Wright the pattern is everything
mathematics all that happens right I'm
generalizing is a big problem
identifying the common ratio students
get totally weirded out by that I think
is one will be other when they try to
clear King jr. no yeah exactly don't
give me a huge about just like it's
writing but it's intelligent ask you
want to think about like oh yeah it's a
GP only one pair what knowing how yes
what kind of this question this question
to be fair was a question 16 two years
ago the HSE this is a question 16 so
question 16 vente me the hardest
question in the paper but like I would
say there's only really one curveball on
this question is this guy this is what
makes it gross I think once you get a
little more practice you will find those
steps end up in the same every time you
do turn one term to your turn three then
you think a keg what's the first term
what's the ratio and in terms do I have
and those are the same every time
thank you have harder to unity okay now
just to finish up what i'm going to say
that you can keep on working on i hope
everyone got the email today one get it
yes if you didn't let me know and i'll
send it again i would try to produce yes
yes oh yes I do thank you for mine I do
um all of the stages to finish is number
one this afternoon we're going to do one
on one more different application of
series and sequences I'll show you this
afternoon it's geometry it didn't make
it into the the the big 60 pages or how
many pitch there are because when I when
I tagged Susan secretive it didn't get
tagged you know but it is Susan
sequences um we ended up this afternoon
and in terms of like you know how I said
curveballs right I'm so having a ratio
dog like this that's a couple another
kind of thing that we could change is it
the question might say for her first ten
years Joe puts in this amount and then
at the tenth year she realizes oh wait I
want to I want to get a certain target
when I when I'm finished when I'm
retired right so therefore I need to
adjust my repayment how much do I adjust
my repayment by now so then what you do
is you would say for instance you would
say okay here's what a ten days and
you'll get a number key and then you're
safe now pause freeze she's going to
change her behavior right so now a new
call it feels like that a new series
begins right and then 15 years will go
so in be 50 and I want that to be a
certain number I want that to be like a
million dollars right and then you
almost treat it as a new question
because it's a new series in operation
okay these are the classic ways that
they take something which is voids it's
quite formulate once you get some
practice there and then they try and
just turn it a little bit sideways so
that people who are just learning the
formula and the steps by themselves
without understanding what each of these
terms are so that those students get
so that's how they distinguished